- You've been out on the front lines
at protests recently.
Has that experience given you hope?
Or has it kind of deterred you?
I feel like
I know several people that have gone
and there've been
different kinds of protests
and different happenings in each one.
So what is your experience been like?
- It makes me feel hopeful personally
because the protests have
not stopped since May.
And we're now in June
and I don't see them
slowing down or stopping.
- Is there any particular
moment that has really stood out for you?
Like since May and now
we're moving into June?
- Um, no particular moments.
I mean, it's just
really depressing to wake up,
open Twitter and go
Oh, okay.
- Yeah
- Somebody else is dead
- Yeah.
- Yeah
And I don't know
if things will go back to normal.
I mean, at least not for black people.
We talk about it ad nauseum.
I talk about it in my stand ups.
So like, I don't know
if there is like a going back.
Like if you're not
radicalized for forever,
like, you're part of the problem.
And I encourage a lot of white people
to read white fragility.
It is a wonderful book
that truly breaks down
why white people don't
wanna talk about race.
And why their discomfort seems to,
you know, take precedent over learning.
- And why, like,
i think a lot of people
don't even notice it.
They don't see it.
You know what I'm saying?
- Oh yeah
- It's like f you're in it,
you don't even see it a lot sometimes.
And its
- Oh, yeah absolutely
- Not until you listen
and have conversations
to where you see the difference.
And you hear the difference
that you actually go, hmm okay?
Like, you know
I think that's a big problem
about it too, is the ignorance.
I think educating oneself
is probably the most important thing
you can do right now.
Other than listening